what's up guys I know you probably
didn't expect this video because I was
whining about my finals and how I
couldn't really play roller coaster in
three because of them which is partly
true and it's partly sad as well but
then again I had history in the morning
yesterday and today I have economics in
the afternoon and there was quite a bit
of time between that so yesterday
afternoon I felt like just doing some
roller coastering three stuff because I
had a little bit of a flash of
inspiration which has everything to do
with the entire Transylvanian theme
that's been going on and it's also kind
of justified by rct3 Tommy's awesome
building because he also decided to make
something Transylvanian after he saw my
building and I looked at it and I was
like wow the [ __ ] you just knocked me
out of the park with that style and I
couldn't resist but open the game and
see if the Romanian theme would actually
be OK for park entrance because here's
the here's the thing that I've been
struggling with it's the overall layout
of the park and it's definitely
something in which I felt Rose garnon's
kind of failed because even though
unlike the park on a small aspect as in
I like the areas on their own but the
paths work and the overall layout of the
park doesn't really seem to be too great
to me and that's something that I wanted
to avoid with this new Park so I kind of
wanted to plan it out more but I felt
like I wasn't really ready to start
doing stuff like the main street and the
entrance building and the train station
for example but when I but when I saw
his building I was pretty convinced that
the Romanian style would actually work
out for many more things than just that
little Palace I built so decided to open
up my game and this is all completely
experimental by the way so I'm sorry for
any of the experiments that go on in
this time lapse and which caused it to
take quite a while it's pretty long time
ups and there's quite a bit of building
stuff and they're removing it but you
know it's all part of the process so it
doesn't really matter as long as the end
result is pretty cool I guess so I
decided to do that and this building is
many supposed to be some kind of train
station is ish thing it was sort of
inspired by the Europa Park train
station that you have over the entrance
or at least I think it's the train
station at least it looked like it it
was inspired by Roy and I kind of wanted
that but also a mixture of
Disneyland Paris kind of thing because
that has that really big hotel in front
of it and then you go through a gates
and then on the other side you have the
Main Street and that's the kind of thing
that I also wanted to have over here so
that's why I built this building and
decided that if I wanted to go with any
style for the Main Street then it should
be a some what's kind of generic style
that would work for the entire park in
general because I still do want to go
for many different themes but then again
if I wanted to do the Main Street in a
Disney style then I'd get something
we've all seen before and I am pretty
confident at least the Romanian / the
Transylvanian theme has pretty much
shown that it's pretty capable of doing
many things because it has that mixed
you between the Main Street but it also
has those Alpine influences and the
castles and it's just a pretty awesome
theme I think that it can actually fit
for a Main Street because it has all the
elements that you generally want in it
so it has the classical arches and
pillars and things like that you also
have the Tudor style roofs and walls
with the woodwork so I don't really like
the theme in general so that's why I
wanted to try this and after I built
this building I felt confident and
enough about it to make it an entrance
and that's why I decided that this is
going to be the first episode of the new
let's play series and it's not only
let's play series but it's a new parkour
right and that's kind of the back story
behind behind this so um what is this
thing all about you might ask
I really didn't know too well at the
time the only thing that I was really
planning is I wanted a tower in the
middle with a walkway underneath it and
then I wanted to have some wings on both
sides and just slowly gradually get the
building to be lowered towards the sides
and it's it's overall a pretty standard
structure in terms of shape its
religious the details and the use of
materials that's quite unique about this
building though I do want to say about
it then I'm not too sure about the
colors yet it does seem like an awful
lot of that light brown kind of color
but so far I'm pretty happy with it and
if I really wanted to recall her it
that's really not too much work the only
thing that I really
it's let this building do well is to be
to serve as a sort of entrance building
now mind you this is not going to be the
real entrance building this is not going
to be the building where you pass
through the gates and have the tickets
and stuff kinda wanna have a square in
front of this building and in front of
that square I want to have some very
small buildings for the tickets where
you buy the tickets and where you pass
through the gates and stuff like that
and beyond this building is going to be
the gates that leads to the Main Street
I think that's it's a pretty solid
planning and what I wanted to do with
the rest of the park is a very
disney-esque kind of realistic park I
want to divide it into different
sections but each like each section is
going to be a lot smaller than I
originally planned to and like I did in
Freneau Valley it's going to be more
like Disney except I wanted to use some
themes that are much more obscure and
less common than the themes in Disney so
I wanted to have a Dutch / Flemish
section and I'm still definitely going
to do that that's one of the themes I
really want to use there is going to be
probably a Romanian section with
probably some consoles stuff like that
and the Baltic section is definitely
going to happen and when it comes to
other things I really don't know and I'm
counting on my fingers right now I'm
like having some sort of presentation
but I'm talking into a microphone when I
may have been doing and some other
themes are just I'm thinking I'm under
there I'm thinking about having a
Japanese theme and some other Asian
stuff as well maybe an Arabian theme
though those things are probably still a
bit too mainstream something that I've
been wanting to try out for a very long
time as an Indian theme because I feel
like barely anyone is really doing those
things but I really like them and it's
pretty unique and also has some really
cool elements and takes a lot of
elements from other things and that's I
think that's the most important thing
that I want to have for themes in this
park because as much as it's fun to use
themes that nobody's ever really done
before it's also a problem because you
don't really have got some scenery sets
for it now the shape that the building
has right now by the way it's going to
be the final shape with just those
alpine things in the side
I was kind of not so sure about the bass
though because the bass did seem a
little bit high so in the end I just
copied this entire structure and lowered
it 1h because that seemed to work out a
lot better than having this very high
bass especially with those pillars it's
perhaps a little bit too high if you you
know you understand that people will
need to walk underneath them but I think
those pillars are four meters high or
something like that it's a six meters
probably so that's a bit too much and
that's really the only problem that I
have with this building some other
problem is I think it was Dutch who said
it that this building might actually be
too big and imposing for an entrance
building and it fit more like dark right
kind of building which in hindsight I
kind of had to say that I kind of agreed
on that it's pretty damn big and
imposing for just no one enter this kind
of building but then again I already
built it as an entrance I really don't
want to go through the entire process of
rebuilding this thing to make it a dark
right section especially considering the
fact that after multiple tries I finally
got something that I really wanted to
have at the entrance of my park because
I tried a couple of other things
actually time lapse them as well but
they didn't really work out as well so
through those things away I still saved
them don't worry they're saved the
structures and I might use them either
for inspiration or to work into another
building but it's really not something
that I really wanted to go for and I
feel like this building is small enough
to be realistic enough to be used in a
theme park like Disney but also not too
big that it's over the top because I do
want to go for realism as stupid as this
sounds we're looking at this building
one of the main inspirations really was
Disney and I did what I should have done
a very long time ago and I should have
done many more times than I've done so
far is just to go to Paris on Google
Maps and go into Disneyland and you can
actually do that on Google Maps I was
quite surprised you can just take Street
View and like walk inside the theme park
and you know looking at the layouts I
decided a couple things that I wanted to
do and looking at how the various
attractions are spaced from each other
is stuff like that that was just kind of
like some background study that I should
have done a long time ago because as
much as I like in the
buildings I've always been struggling
with the way that you make up a theme
park and that's been one of the issues
that I really wanted to address in this
Pike and wanted to fix for once and for
all and that is going to happen
hopefully I really can't promise too
many things but hopefully that's going
to happen also something that I do want
to do in this let's play is I'm going to
have summer vacation pretty damn soon
and I'm gonna try to no lie for a second
three as much as I can and just record
as many things as I can and if I decide
that something doesn't really work out
too well I guess I'll just have to throw
it away because I'd rather actually go
the perfectionistic route with this park
and end up throwing away a lot of work
but in the end having a beautiful park
then just keep on working with something
that I'm not really a big I know and
then in the end having spent a lot of
efforts on something that I'm not a huge
fan of so this park is going to
incorporate a lot of planning and a lot
of working ahead and certain things so
it might take a long time but then again
hopefully it's going to pay out I mean
it's going to pay off in the end and the
backside of this building by the way is
a lot more alpine than the front which
is something that I wasn't really sure
about because I wasn't really sure how
an alpine Main Street would work at
least I know how an alpine Main Street
kind of works and how a well Main Street
Main Street I think it's just generic /
American kind of Main Street but I have
never really seen a mixture like this
for example so it's going to be a bit of
experimentation also on Main Street and
how that is going to work
but I'm kind of looking forward to it
and got loads of ideas that I kind of
went to try out so it's probably going
to work out in the end hopefully
probably that's definitely something
that I'm hoping for now concerning this
entire Park layout thing the way I've
blended so far is to have that ticket
thing in the prompt and after that have
a pretty cool Square with like a
fountain or something cool like that
whatever Disney does in their squares I
might do something similar and then this
building and then the Main Street with
just some various shops maybe a couple
of dark rides I really don't know yet I
guess we'll just seen
the near future and after that you know
some kind of standard walkway Bulevar
ish thing and a cool square in the
middle of the park and then from the
middle of the park it's going to branch
out into various directions and various
themes or which I want to try many
things by the way and there's so many
ideas in my head that I kind of win
there to give a shot and the only thing
that I'm not sure of is whether I want
to do like this noise those whether I
want to have a concert or something like
that in the middle because one thing
with this park is that it has this style
that I have for the entrance is gonna
it's gonna be the main generic ish tile
for the rest of this bike but I'm not
really sure if I can really build in a
castle with that in the middle of the
park and whether that would be too much
of Disney ripoff because I don't want a
ripoff Disney it's going to be my mainly
my inspiration not for the themes but
for the Pikul layouts so that's
something to keep in mind so I might
actually built like a skyscraper or
something in the middle of the park a
hotel or I'm not really sure yet but
we'll see I guess maybe a Romanian
castle or it's just nothing in the
middle of the park just the square and
stuff around that that's something then
I'll just have to see about in the
future maybe some people kind of have
some awesome suggestions because I
definitely am not the only person who
can come up with everything and that
will also because some scenery and I am
not really sure yet if I really want to
feature that in the in the last play
episodes because you know that nut might
turn into boring and Sketch up
shenanigans and it takes quite a while
to import and make up some scenery but I
am planning to if I if I you know find
pieces that I really want to use but
don't have yet in custom scenery I
definitely want to just mow all those
pieces and import them and in the end
maybe end up with a corset just for this
park that I can release so that people
can use some cool stuff but the one
thing that I'm not really sure about yet
if is if I want to feature that in the
let's play because if I'm going to do
that then it's going to be quite an
important aspect of this point and it's
also going to be quite a bit of time
that I put into this pike just to make
that work but then again it's not really
the standard letsplay thing to watch
people make custom scenery and it's a
it's not really the most exciting thing
so
I'm really debating whether I should
feature that in my videos somehow maybe
turn it into a miniseries aside from
this park or if I were to feature it at
all and just keep it to my live streams
and to be very fair because I'm scenery
making live streams aren't really too
much fun either but you know because
some city making is something that I'll
have to do anyway and now I've been
doing it mostly and alone up until this
point but sometimes you just can't find
enough motivation to import sand or to
model and import the custom scenery that
you want to have though honestly it's
mostly the importing third I always
struggle with not because it's hard
because but because it's just such a
tedious thing to do and I always get
ahead of myself when building custom
scenery that I start thinking of things
that I want to use it for without even
having imported it into the game yet and
then I start wanting that piece but then
I still have to import it but my my
craving for the piece is not as much as
the will to actually import it and it's
just general problems alright and that's
something that I wanted to avoid is so
I'll see if I can feature that somehow
whether that would actually be a good
idea
I might just mess around with that idea
and I guess we'll just see in the end
what's going to happen with the custom
scenery issues and really I feel like
many more things that I expected
beforehand can be done with custom
scenery I expected that just to make
this kind of style this Transylvanian
Romanian theme work I would have to
import many pieces because looking at
some castles then I found in Romania
they actually have many pieces that you
don't have in rollercoaster good three
but then again you can pretty much build
very similar things with custom scenery
we already have and although it doesn't
look the same it still has the same kind
of shape and it gets the same idea
across
so really the more I look at it the more
uncertain I become that I'd really have
to make new custom scenery but it's
something that I went to try out and
something that can definitely help the
park look better especially for things
like having the name of the park in
fountains and things like that and if I
really wanted to have really unique
buildings then I definitely need to get
to that
for the main street though and for the
path work and stuff like that I am
pretty much good now many sets for that
and I've picked up quite a bit of quite
a lot of sets lately that I never really
worked with before but turn out to be
quite good sets so oh all I know I I
don't really feel too bad about this
haul cause some scenery deal and getting
more custom scenery to make new things
with but it's just something that I
wanted to consider because it seemed
like like something that could be worth
it and something that I've never done
before but yeah at this point the
building is pretty much finished and
pretty much looking badass this is just
a picture of it and even though I'm not
really sure about the base yet I feel
like it's good enough and especially on
the backside where the base is less
prominent I really like it and that was
one loss pick I still suck at this
editing with clouds and stuff like that
but I looked at this castle when I was
like earth mmm could use some clouds in
the background maybe that would look
cool and I guess I was right it does
look pretty cool with some clouds in the
background so this is it this is the
building and this is the first episode
of the let's play I mean the new let's
play park and I'll see you on the next
episode so till then thanks for watching